if we all disappeared tomorrow 5 million
years from now aliens could colonize
Earth and never even realize we existed
if there was an advanced civilization on
Earth that died out millions of years
ago how would we know thanks to the
inherent Rarity of fossilization it's
thought that only around
0.1% of all the species that ever lived
are represented in the fossil record the
other 90 99.9% we're talking several
billion species are just God we have no
way of knowing what they were or when
and how they lived in other words if
there was an advanced civilization on
Earth millions of years ago we certainly
couldn't rely on fossils to identify
them and if we couldn't detect them in
the fossil record or by finding the
remains of their artifacts and cities we
would have no way of knowing they
existed at
all